[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy hablamos con motivo del 8 de
marzo sobre la igualdad de género en la
unión europea que se está haciendo para
reducir la desigualdad es una quimera
acabar con el techo de cristal y que se
ha hecho contra la violencia machista
sobre todas estas cuestiones les invito
a escuchar la conversación que tenemos
hoy con la eurodiputada el líder del
grupo socialdemócrata iratxe garcía
pérez bienvenida a iratxe muchas gracias
y con la vicepresidenta de la comisión
de igualdad y derechos de la mujer maría
eugenia rodríguez para lo peor diputada
de la izquierda europea bienvenida
muchas gracias gracias a las dos por
estar aquí me gustaría empezar dando
algunos datos una de cada tres mujeres
en la unión europea es decir 62 millones
de mujeres ha sufrido violencia física o
sexual desde los 15 años una de cada dos
ha sufrido acoso sexual y el 38 por
ciento de todos los asesinatos en el
mundo son cometidos por sus parejas o
por sus ex parejas que os dicen estas
cifras iratxe pues que la realidad tan
cruda que tenemos en europa y en todo el
mundo evidencia una sociedad es igual
una sociedad donde la mitad de la
población que son los hombres se
consideran con más poder y más derechos
que la otra mitad que somos las mujeres
y por lo tanto creo que es importante
antes de iniciar cualquier debate poder
poner encima de la mesa estos datos que
evidencian la necesidad de avanzar y de
trabajar en la lucha por la igualdad
entre hombres y mujeres somos la mitad
de la población europea y es necesario
avanzar en esas políticas de género en
esas políticas feministas que hagan de
europa un espacio más digno y más justo
las mujeres siguen muriendo en el mundo
y en europa siguen perdiendo la vida en
manos de sus agresores y eso nos da la
clara muestra de que todavía es
insuficiente el trabajo que se ha hecho
por parte de las instituciones y por lo
tanto que necesitamos seguir avanzando
las instituciones la sociedad y la
política tiene una gran responsabilidad
en este sentido el 8 de marzo es una
fecha señalada es una fecha donde
mujeres y hombres salimos a las calles a
reivindicar esos espacios más justos
esos espacios de igualdad donde
representamos todos los derechos por los
que tenemos que seguir trabajando con
una perspectiva claramente feminista
maria eugenia que nos dicen estas cifras
bueno nos dice todo lo que queda por
hacer
estos datos que acabas de mencionar
proceden de encuestas que ha hecho la
agencia de derechos fundamentales de la
unión europea pero tenemos el problema
de que no hay una tipificación
idéntica en los diferentes estados hay
solamente dos estados que hablan de
violencia de género hay diez que hablan
de violencia doméstica y el resto
subsume la violencia contra las mujeres
en otros tipos en otro penales pueden
ser los homicidios las agresiones esto
significa que ya no hay una homogeneidad
que nos permita recabar datos fidedignos
hemos luchado para que en el parlamento
de más mayoritariamente apoyado para que
la violencia de género sea considerado
un euro delito
ha tenido un apoyo masivo por parte del
parlamento vamos a tener sin embargo
problemas en el consejo también tenemos
problemas en el consejo para ratificar
el convenio de estambul porque hay
determinados gobiernos y me gusta hablar
de gobiernos no de países pues son
gobiernos que se oponen permanentemente
a cualquier avance de los derechos de
las mujeres y hemos tenido problemas con
el reconocimiento de los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos especialmente
en algunos países de la unión europea o
sea que aún nos queda muchísimo por
hacer nos han prometido una directiva
que aborde de manera integral esta
violencia que junto con la ratificación
del convenio estambul sabemos que podría
reducir en un 10 por ciento de la
violencia contra las mujeres entonces
vamos a trabajar dado que lo de la
ratificación bueno depende de gobiernos
en el consejo que
no parece que vayan a avanzar o que
vayan a dar un paso adelante no vamos a
apostar al menos por esta directiva que
nos ha prometido defender la hiena y en
el debate sobre estado de la unión
justamente quería preguntar por esto
porque según un estudio citado por la
eurocámara se registran 3.500 muertes
todos los años por violencia machista en
europa la pandemia ha hecho retrasar
esta directiva como comentabas ahora la
guerra en ucrania que es lo que está
impidiendo que que se esté tardando
tanto bueno nosotros hemos planteado ya
la presidenta de la comisión a la señora
von der layen este retraso porque
tenemos que recordar que fue en el mes
de septiembre en el debate del estado de
la unión cuando ya se comprometió por
fin a poner encima de la mesa una
propuesta de ley que los grupos
políticos y la mayoría aquí en el
parlamento llevábamos mucho tiempo
planteando no una ley que abarque la
necesidad de avanzar en la lucha contra
la violencia de las mujeres en todos los
países de la unión europea dijo que
antes de finales de año estaría esa
propuesta no está
y evidentemente es necesario que cumpla
su palabra la presidenta de la comisión
europea somos conscientes de que hay
muchísimas otras cuestiones en la agenda
pero no puede ser que siempre sean los
temas de las mujeres los que queden en
un segundo plano por otros motivos o por
otras circunstancias la pandemia también
ha demostrado tener una clara
perspectiva de género no teníamos
pensemos que teníamos a miles y miles de
mujeres
confinadas en sus casas con sus
maltratadores durante el tiempo de
confinamiento tengamos en cuenta que
muchas de las mujeres que trabajan en
sectores donde el trabajo no regulado
como el servicio doméstico es una
realidad pues se vieron también
afectadas por lo tanto también la
pandemia tuvo esa perspectiva de género
no podemos dejar que otros asuntos
siempre dejen en segundo plano las
cuestiones tan tan importantes que
estamos abordando y por lo tanto creo
que no hay mejor momento que este 8 de
marzo para reivindicar ya de una vez por
todas que la comisión europea cumple su
palabra y ponga encima de la mesa una
propuesta legislativa que evidentemente
tendrá que ser debatida y negociada
dentro de este parlamento con todos los
grupos políticos y posteriormente con
los gobiernos pero en cualquier caso
todo ese proceso necesita iniciarse y
para eso es fundamental tener ya la
propuesta legislativa mar ingenia antes
estabas hablando del bloqueo de algunos
gobiernos a ciertas leyes de una de
ellas es la de las cuotas de mujeres en
los consejos empresariales que lleva
también años bloqueada ahora la comisión
europea dice que quiere volverla a
impulsar esta vez podría salir adelante
bueno parece que francia lo tiene
bastante claro ojalá salga adelante y
eso que ha quedado en cierto modo
desfasada porque hablamos de una
directiva que lleva durmiendo el sueño
de los justos pues desde el año 2012
entonces bueno ha llovido mucho desde
entonces lo que plantea es algo tan
simple como la heterogeneidad en los
consejos de administración un 40-60 que
no solamente es una cuestión de justicia
es una cuestión de eficiencia sabemos lo
sabemos por estudios
los consejos de administración cuando
son heterogéneos es decir combinan
hombres mujeres diferentes razas
diferentes formas de ver el mundo
diferentes religiones bueno pues ofrecen
mejores condiciones laborales y además
mejores resultados en la gestión de
bueno la gestión que se está haciendo en
la empresa entonces bueno es una
cuestión a mí me parece básica y después
bueno tiene el defecto esa directiva de
que se reduce a un determinado número de
empresas no y que además se orienta
sobre todo a cuerpos no ejecutivos
nosotros nos gustaría que además de
ponerse en marcha pues también se
revisará y actualizará pero tenemos la
confianza que la presidencia francesa la
reactiva claro en cualquier caso en este
sentido como decía maría eugenia la
presencia francesa la puede activar con
motivo de que ya hay uno de los
gobiernos que estaba planteando la
minoría de bloqueo que es el gobierno de
alemania que ha cambiado ha cambiado de
posición y creo que eso debemos de
tenerlo en cuenta y nos da una
oportunidad para debatir porque una vez
que se desbloquee por parte del y tengan
una posición común comenzaremos a
negociar entre consejo y parlamento y
ahí abrimos nuevamente el debate y
podemos adaptarlo es cierto a una
realidad distinta podemos abordar otras
cuestiones y llegar a acuerdos pero lo
que necesitábamos sin duda era que se
desbloqueará en el consejo y que nos
podamos sentar a negociar hay habrá
distintas posiciones negociaremos y
tendremos que trabajar para conseguir
una posición común no pero el hecho de
que ya haya un desbloqueo en el consejo
es una buena señal
las mujeres en todos los países de la ue
según datos de la comisión europea del
ajuste sin excepción superan siempre el
tiempo dedicado a labores del hogar
respecto a sus parejas hombres que para
ya falta educación falta empatía qué es
lo que pasa mira falta educación en el
sentido de que las mujeres están
segregadas de algunos espacios
educativos sabemos por ejemplo que las
niñas no acceden a las carreras stem
igual que los niños lo que significa que
después en el espacio laboral que ofrece
pues esas carreras están marginadas
sabemos que hay segregación horizontal y
vertical las mujeres en el espacio
laboral sabemos que las mujeres están
precarizados es decir que ganan menos
que los hombres estamos ahora mismo
informando una directiva de
transparencia salarial donde queda de
manifiesto que es una brecha salarial de
género pues de un 14.8 si no me equivoco
en la unión europea que después se
traduce en un treinta y tantos por
ciento de brecha en pensiones o sea que
nuestras abuelas son más pobres que
nuestros abuelos precisamente por
haberse dedicado a labores domésticas y
de cuidados hay 8 millones de mujeres
que han dejado de trabajar en el espacio
público para dedicarse a cuidar frente a
medio millón de varones es decir que
esto es claro y tiene que ver con las
condiciones salariales y con las
condiciones laborales hay dos cuestiones
en marcha en la unión europea que nos
pueden dar una esperanza respecto de
esta cuestión una vez por supuesto la
directiva de conciliación que en muchos
estados no han implementado aunque sea
todavía bastante limitada y otra es una
estrategia europea de cuidados que
esperamos que empiece su andadura pues
después del verano y que nosotras vamos
a impulsar con muchísimo entusiasmo
porque ahí se pondrán en valor a las
cuidadoras además de garantizar el
derecho a los cuidados de las personas
dependientes
ustedes son políticas llevan ya algunos
años a sus espaldas y se han sentido
juzgadas por ejemplo por su aspecto
físico más que su mujeres más que sus
compañeros hombres irache
es verdad que tenemos que hacer frente a
multitud de estereotipos
en cuanto a lo físico pero no solo
también es verdad que nosotras tenemos
muchas veces que demostrar capacidades
que nuestros compañeros se les dan por
supuesto no
este argumento cuando lo utilizamos en
muchas ocasiones cuando defendemos la
paridad y defendemos las cuotas quienes
estamos en esa posición porque este
argumento que nos deja siempre en un
segundo plano diciendo que estén los que
valen sean hombres son mujeres siempre
ha intentado explicar una realidad que
es una sociedad desigual no me creo por
ejemplo que cuando vemos imágenes de
gobiernos donde no hay ni una sola mujer
es porque no haya ninguna mujer que vale
acaso todos los que están todos los
hombres que están valen esto claramente
definen los estereotipos y que nosotros
tenemos que estar continuamente
demostrando nuestras capacidades
tenemos que estar justificando que
estamos donde estamos porque podemos
hacerlo
y creo que esa es otra cuestión muy muy
evidente que demuestra todo lo que queda
por hacer la lucha contra estereotipos
es fundamental y por lo tanto bueno pues
quizá quienes estamos en este primer
plano de la política tenemos más
responsabilidad todavía pero conscientes
de que las mujeres feministas que
estamos defendiendo esta posición lo que
estamos haciendo es abrir camino para
muchas otras que quizá tengan otra
perspectiva de ver la realidad pero que
también posibilitan que este mundo
cambie el movimiento feminista en el
mundo ha dado grandes oportunidades a
todas las mujeres y también ahí tenemos
que ser conscientes de lo que nos queda
por hacer
muchísimas gracias iratxe mar ingenia
lamentablemente nos hemos quedado sin
tiempo pero este debate hay que seguirlo
muchísimas gracias a las dos y a ustedes
les esperamos en el próximo programa de
europa hoy gracias por ver france24 en
español
[Música]